[Music]
hey marvel's avengers fans we're excited
to show you all of the updates you can
expect on next generation consoles
available for upgrades starting march
18th at no additional awesome from the
minute you boot up the game to getting
back into the action after being down
faster load times make sure that you can
get back to fighting aim as fast as
possible
higher resolution textures and
translucency will bring a new level of
detail to objects characters
environments and even particles you'll
see improvements across the board
including ambient occlusion quality and
isotropic filtering and 60fps at 4k
hulk smashes are even bigger with our
improved destruction smashing through
walls doors and enemies is always fun
with the big green guy and with improved
destruction the possibilities for hulk
epic smashes are endless not to be
outdone all of our heroes will see an
improvement in their unique heroics
across the board if you're playing on a
playstation 5 expect to feel each smash
even more with the ps5's advanced
controller haptics
finally teaming up as earth's mightiest
heroes has never been easier with cross
generation multiplayer allowing you to
continue to team up with friends within
the same console family
thanks for joining and we're excited for
you to experience this definitive
superhero experience of marvel's
avengers for console players starting
march 18th at no additional cost